without further ado my name is rebecca
kozak i am
honored to be your host for the askdoc
live program that we have available to
you
every friday pacific time it's 9 00 a.m
so
wherever you are go ahead and add or
subtract
time um to make it no no it's not
no it's not it's 8 a.m what did i say
you said 9. oh it's 8.
i'm so glad you're paying attention dr
wallach
i looked at my watch i said am i on an
hour later what's going on
no no i'm was talking to somebody in
colorado this morning and
had that nine o'clock their time yeah
mountain time that's right
all right yesterday i was talking to
israel they're ten hours
ahead so when it's friday afternoon here
it's a saturday at midnight there
right right yeah well and i love the
fact that it makes
it's so easy now to connect with people
in the world
that's it's i love it i love it
well again welcome everybody to ask doc
live this i just want everybody to know
that the content
of this program is to provide
nutritional education information only
this program is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician
the fda requires us to let you know that
our products are not meant to treat
prevent
diagnose or cure any disease
any testimonial shared on this program
is a real life
testimony from people that have been
trying dr wallach's products and gave
him
what he always asks give me 90 days 90
days
and i'm so glad that i gave him that 90
five years ago almost dr wallach it's
gonna be five years
in march um but as empowered
individuals you have options available
and this program has been put together
to be able to help you discover and find
and implement those options
without further ado i am so
so honored to be able to host
dr joel wallick and on behalf of
myself and my co-hosts welcome to
ask doc live dr wallach well thank you
rebecca and thank you so much for all
you do
very very proud of you and to see here
how much weight have you lost
95 pounds well it looks good on you
let me take that back it looks good off
of you
that's right very proud of you thank you
okay well i have bad news and good news
the bad news
is um last night we went up 2 000 more
deaths in the united states
2 000 more deaths um and we went up in
infections um new infections we went up
uh let's see here oh my gosh
when we went up a hundred
a hundred and fifty six thousand new
infections
in america okay from this pandemic virus
6 000 yeah new infections
yeah 156 000 new infections
yesterday it was 25 million 498 000
today is 25 million 546
excuse me 556 000 so we went up 156 000
new infections
and 2 000 new dead now let's go back
to a year and a half ago when fauci was
put in place
dr arnold fauci and he said look this
this pandemic virus isn't nothing we
have the recordings we know exactly we
have him with a smiling face saying
this isn't nothing just wash your hands
wear a mask and stay six feet apart and
all
be well and you know in a couple of
months we'll have a vaccine and no big
deal
well what have we gotten for a year and
a half listening to dr fauci
25 million 556 000 infections
435 241 dead
that doesn't sound like a nothing in
arlington seminary which has all of our
military dead from the civil war
forward we only have 400
000 buried there so for all of our wars
since the civil war
we have 400 000 dead buried in our
beautiful sanctuary for them the people
we loved and
appreciate their sacrifices our military
four hundred thousand dead and listening
to dr
fauci in one year we have four hundred
and thirty five thousand two hundred
forty one dead
that's incredible that's incredible
and then they kept saying now you'll
remember this rebecca they kept saying
you know the vaccine's coming the
vaccine's coming
well about a week ago president biden
like
the day after he gets you know in office
he says uh
uh uh uh um
we um we're not gonna be able to control
the
spiking of this um pandemic virus
because of christmas and new years and
all the holidays and blah blah blah
blah it's going crazy nothing we can do
about it
sam why on earth would he come out and
say that well the very next day
merck the biggest pharmaceutical company
in the united states maybe the world
come out and said well the two
vaccines we were just about ready to
release are not giving us any immunity
for people and so we're dumping them
we're gathering up all we know about
medicines to give to people who have the
virus we're going to start treating them
as a patient with these medications and
then all the other
vaccine companies are you know like um
pfizer and that sort of stuff they're
jumping up now yeah
our vaccine's coming our vaccine is
coming then two days ago they said
uh uh uh our vaccines aren't working
against the uk and the brazilian and the
australian and the south african
variants
uh uh of the virus so we're holding it
back uh
uh well i predicted this you remember
that
where i said that the kids under the age
of 10 would have a predictable
reaction to the vaccines but people who
are in their middle age you know 50
years old or seniors over
65 are going to have a highly variable
reaction to the vaccines depending on
what they ate
now you have to appreciate that vaccines
do not kill viruses bacteria or fungus
they just alert your body to bad dna and
rnas when the bug hits you whether it's
a bacteria or a virus
or a fungus your body says ah there's
that bad stuff and says the white blood
cells and antibodies and red blood cells
and platelets to kill and eat the
viruses or the bacteria or the fungus
well they forgot there's three other
pieces to being
immune in addition to the vaccinations
now
when um let's see jonas salk
you know credited with the polio vaccine
ended the polio epidemic in kids
i mean it was like overnight they
vaccinated everybody was done boom bang
in two weeks time
polio was gone well that's because it
was all in kids under the age of 10.
they'd only been eating gluten for seven
eight years
middle-aged people are eating it for 50
years seniors eating 50 60 70 years
their villi are dead they cannot absorb
and then secondly doctors have been
telling them for a hundred years ah
don't waste your money on vitamins
minerals just just
eat well you get everything you need so
they don't have any nutrients
to go to their bone marrow to make white
blood cells and antibodies
their bone marrow is dead because the
bone marrow has been starving for
nutrients for their entire life because
they're eating gluten and they're not
supplementing
and then they give them the vaccine and
wonder why it doesn't work
well i predicted this because i've done
32 000 autopsies my thesis of
50 was it 5 000 pages is in the
smithsonian institute's national
treasure they sell for 25
000 each if you
go on siri and amazon you can ask for
them
used and beat up if you can get one for
forty five hundred dollars you're doing
good
if they're in good condition they sell
for eight thousand to twelve thousand if
they're in excellent condition they sell
for
ten to fifteen thousand but brand new in
the box still unopened still in the
wrapper
25 000 to 35 000 and i'm not telling you
that to brag i'm telling you that
because
for credibility people say well what
what do you know wallach
well somebody thought i knew something
because my thesis from 20
000 autopsies is in the smithsonian
institute i showed there were no
genetically transmitted diseases
there are no um particularly transmitted
birth defects they're all nutritional
deficiencies now
this all started at three o'clock in the
afternoon monday september 4th
1882 on pearl street in new york city in
the bluff overlooking the construction
of the brooklyn bridge where thomas
edison
and jonathan liebs pulled the switch in
the first commercial electric
engineering plant
until about three o'clock in the
afternoon monday september 4th
everybody in the world whether they were
a king or a peasant farmer or a
fisherman
or somebody wandering around in the
desert everybody in the world was
supplementing with minerals
they're putting their wood ashes from
their stoves and their fireplaces and
fire pits in their gardens they're
mixing wood ashes in their food
but once electricity came out no more
wood ashes so everybody stopped
taking in mineral supplements
because you could eat well and get
everything you need now that would be
like your mechanic
rebecca saying do not waste your money
on oil but i've got my favorite i mean
my dream car i got my jaguar i want i
don't care if it's 10
a quart i want the best oil for my
jaguar don't waste your money on oil
just get some dirt from texas or
oklahoma there's bound to be some oil in
it
put six quarts of dirt from texas in
your car only 10 cents a quart
well a crazy person would run away
screaming
but when a doctor says oh disease well
get everything you need
my doctor says i can get everything i
need just by eating well
bam you're dead because you can't get
everything you need because nutritional
minerals do not occur in a uniform
blanket around the cost of the earth
they occur in veins like
silver and gold plants only need three
you can buy any commercial fertilizer
you want
they only have three nutrients in it
because that's all the plant needs
farmers don't get paid by the
nutritional value of the food
they get paid by tons and bushels
so they're going to get the cheapest
fertilizer they can get that gives them
the maximum tons of bushels now what do
they do for their animals they give them
vitamins and minerals on top of their
hay and their pellets and all this kind
of stuff
and your doctor says oh just eat well
well within 15
20 years after that everybody in america
started gaining weight prior to that
three o'clock in the afternoon monday
september 4th 1882 the only place you
could see a fat person was in a carnival
or a circus
hubba hubba hubba come see the fat lady
two bucks see the fat lady
because nobody had ever seen a fat
person
right well now 25 years later everybody
got
fat because one of the symptoms of a
mineral deficiency is pica
now rebecca have you ever heard of the
term pica p-i-c-a
yes okay pica is kind of a ravenous
hunger you just want to eat everything
you'll chew on
the doorknob i mean you'll eat your bed
sheets you will do you'll eat bad stuff
i mean you'll eat stuff under the toilet
you're looking for something to satisfy
that craving
little kids do it all the time why are
you doing that that's why they put that
vinyl or that fiberglass sheath on the
crib
because the kids when when they gave
them enfamil and similac
only had three nutrients in it the kids
are starving for minerals they're
chewing on the rails
and so they called it cribbing
they're chewing on the rails because
they're minerally deficient okay and
they started getting
cystic fibrosis and muscular civilian
crib death
and they're all saying these are all
genetic diseases except for crib death
mothers are laying on the babies
well i recognize that and dr milan and i
we went to china we did 1
700 autopsies on kids under the age of
who are dying of keshawn disease which
is a deficiency of a single nutrient
thousand seven hundred autopsy is
published in three languages the english
version
is in the let's see here uh it's in
uh the trace element research okay it's
in a journal called trace helmet
research
the biology of trace helmet research and
we found that 35 of those 1 700
autopsies
had cystic fibrosis 100
had muscular dystrophy and
2 000 of them no let me take that back
200 of them 200 of them
under the age of one year would have
been diagnosed with
crib death in the united states only two
percent of the kids dying of crib death
were mothers
when they were found dead 98 were in
their crib
i forced them to change the name from
sediment destiny room to crib death
because they're all in the cribs not
under the mothers okay well it turns out
it's all the same deficiency
um i had tried for 25 years to get that
nutrient into baby farmers and doctors
so you can't put that in their wallet
it's poisonous they would never put it
in
well on the 16th of april
2013 a federal uh court
ruled in my favor finally that was my
10th win in federal court
to force infamil similac and all the
other baby farmers put that nutrient in
a year and a half later september 13th
2014 headlines
okay we're talking about the charlotte
observer from charlotte north carolina
kind of like new york times in new york
the shot observer i mean we're talking
bold big letters like
third world war stuff we don't know why
but sediment death syndrome has
vanished in the state of north carolina
because i had that nutrient in the baby
farmless for a year and a half
then three months later st louis
post-dispatch all the newspapers in the
state of missouri came out and said we
don't know why but sentiment death
syndrome has vanished in the state
of missouri then three months later
every newspaper in the world rebecca
came out and said
we don't know why but cinema death
syndrome has vanished
by 95 to 9 95 percent in all the
countries of the world
that's because it was really just a
nutritional deficiency causing the same
heart attack
that was caused in these kids that dr
milan and i did the autopsy study on now
here comes a new study that came out
just two days ago
there's a new disease out called
multiple inflammatory
syndrome dash c for children
that's multi-inflammatory syndrome
syndrome yeah
m-i-s-c okay
in this publication they had 1 600
autopsies about the same that we had
with ours 1
700. and they said these kids are all
dying of heart disease which is what
this keyshawn disease was that we went
to china to deal with
they're all dying of heart disease
sudden this is called
uh hypertrophic cardiomyopathy heart
disease liver cirrhosis
brain hemorrhages pulmonary issues and
blah blah blah blah blah
and they all test positive for covet
well these kids had coveted
for a year no problem they died from
that nutritional deficiency
okay and they're all finding this
mysterious they haven't read my paper
yet okay
now here's the giveaway 75
of these kids who they published the
autopsies on here on the mis multiple
inflammatory syndrome dash c
just a couple of days ago 75 percent are
latinos
hmm why would you think that is
gluten alert gluten alert gluten alert
because they're eating
flour tortillas pancakes waffles
spaghetti oatmeal for breakfast you got
it
it's not genetic doctor well not genetic
that is correct
and so when they came out and said you
know
we have all these problems here the
indigenous peoples
uh out of a hundred thousand you know uh
people who are infected uh 133 to 168
depending on whose daddy you look at
the indigenous peoples in america are
dying um
like every month uh the black people per
hundred thousand
infected 124 to 168 depending on whose
data you're looking at
the polynesians which are hawaiians and
that kind of stuff
um are knight and also the inuit
eskimos from alaska 90
die every month per 100
000 infected and then the latinos
mexican spanish
you got it you know south americans um
so forth
87 to 99 die per month per 100 000
infected
white people in america 75 die per 100
every month in fact in the asians only
54 die
so what's the difference between an
asian and a native american gluten alert
gluten alert gluten alert because the
asians live on rice
and sweet potatoes and maize corn
and beans and seaweed
and the native americans live on wheat
oats
barley and rye gluten alert okay now
let's look at some
stuff here that's going to blow your
mind
okay now let's compare vietnam
with 96 million people with texas
that has 29 million people so vietnam
has
in population about three times the
population of texas
vietnam as of just yesterday had 35 dead
from the pandemic virus 35 just 35
1 500 infected texas with one third of
their population
has 2.2 million infections and 34 000
dead now is 34 000 dead more than 35
is 2.2 million infections more than 1500
so what's the difference well texas has
40 percent
latinos black and about five different
native american tribes all of whom are
eating gluten
so 40 to 50 percent of these figures are
these three
races it's not a racial thing it's a
dietary thing let's look
let's look at some more here let's look
at the
ojibwe indians from northern minnesota
up around the great lakes
versus the navajos in arizona okay both
native american tribes
they both have about 355
000 population in their main
reservation the ojibwes in minnesota
have zero deaths
and 27 infections
the navajo indians have 848
dead almost a thousand dead and 25
000 infections so what's the difference
between 25 000 infections and 27
infections
what's the difference between 838 dead
versus zero dead
uh gluten because the navajos live on
wheat barley ryan oates
and of course the ojibwe indians are the
asians of all the indian nations
they're our version of asians they've
been living on wild rice
for 400 years when they immigrated into
to
minnesota from florida because they're
trying to escape all the hurricanes and
all that kind of stuff 400 years ago
when they moved into
minnesota they didn't have any money to
buy land to grow corn and wheat and that
kind of stuff
so they just lived along the banks of
the lakes and just ate free
wild rice they've been eating free wild
rice for 400 years
it's not a genetic thing they have zero
dead only 27 infections
whereas their brothers the navajos in
arizona
same population as 858 dead
and 24 000 infected because they're
living on wheat brother on oats
let's look at a couple more and i think
you'll have it let's compare mexico
with japan
um japan and mexico both have about
120 627 000 people
about millions give 127 000 million both
of them
mexico has 1.8 million almost 2 million
infections and 150 000 dead
japan has 300
000 infections and 5 000 dead
okay let's look at uh one more let's
look at
our polynesians here let's look at
hawaii versus
okinawa which is one of the original
five blue zones
remember the term blue zones it was
published on the you're probably too
young
it was published in 2005 on the cover
of the national geographic dan buettner
was the guy who wrote the article
he picked out five places on earth where
their average life span's a hundred
there are small little communities in
america it's in loma linda
um california where the seventh-day
adventists live
now i don't have any figures for them
because they haven't published them they
may not have any figures to give
okay but in loma linda their average
lifespan is 90
and they have the most hundred-year-olds
of anybody in america
okay so they're one of the five blue
zones then of course there's sardinia
italy
and so forth other places well okinawa
is one of the five blue zones okay it's
a
island very much like the main island of
hawaii
okay they're polynesians
so okinawa and hawaii both with
1 million 440
000 people one million four hundred
forty thousand people both of them
okinawa has 84 dead and five
almost 6 000 infected hawaii has 342
dead and 25 000 infected so what's the
difference between hawaii
and okinawa well hawaii there are 50
estate and they began to eat oatmeal for
breakfast
and wheaties for breakfast pancakes
waffles flour tortillas from their
latino brothers
and in okinawa they're extremely
isolated and they live on rice
and beans and corn and squash and
seaweed
so they're staying away from those
processed foods that are in a box
ready to just add water
because you add water to something
that's gluten you heat it up and you're
ready to go
like it's convenient but not healthy dr
wahlik
well right of course and of course the
asians okinawa they live on
rice beer rice wine
whereas the hive the hawaiians are
drinking budweiser made from
wheat okay got it
okay and so um and
it's crazy i'll give you one more if i
made uh let's
let's compare
let's see here the philippines with
vietnam again
the filipinos i have 109 million
population and vietnam again has
96 million so they're close but um
see the filipinos have 13 more million
people than do the vietnamese
the vietnamese again have 35 dead
and 1 500 infections the filipinos and i
did a big zoom with them last night i'd
do that every thursday night i do a
one-hour zoom with them beautiful people
but remember
vietnam has 35 dead the filipinos have
000 dead the vietnamese have 1
500 1500 infections the filipinos have
515 000 infections is 515 000
more than 1500 is 10 000
more than 35. so what's the difference
between the filipinos who
are polynesian people live in the
philippine
island chains right so why does vietnam
have so little
well because they're still living on
rice
sweet potatoes beans squash corn and
seaweed
whereas the filipinos we've been there
okay
um since um
you know since the second world war with
our military personnel and everybody's
eating wheat
around oats
got it i got it i hope everybody else
has gotten it too well you have to
supplement
okay stay away from gluten your villi
will grow back
and remember i predicted that the kids
would have a predictable result to the
vaccinations under age 10
because they haven't been eating gluten
for too long they still have some villi
but when you've been eating gluten for
25 30 40 years or more those villi go
away and now your intestines are like a
plastic tube you've lost 98 of the
absorptive surface
and if you're not supplement anything
what is zero of zero
nothing so your bone marrow dies and
your bone marrow is your immune system
now rebecca you know of people
you know of people who go to the doctor
once a month or you've heard of people
that go to the doctor once a month to
get
an iron shot or b12 shot because they're
chronically anemic
and when that doesn't work anymore for
them they give them a transfusion
every month or so to get red blood cells
and platelets so they're not bleeding
under their skin and getting
nosebleeds and have to use a whole roll
of toilet paper when they nick
themselves shaving
because they don't have any platelets to
stop the bleeding right
now the next thing that happens is your
mom was one of them
there you go now the next thing that
happens is they say well
you know you're 75 years old you got to
expect this but your bone marrow is dead
you have
medullary dysplasia you don't have
anything going on in your bone marrow
anymore
to make platelets red blood cells white
blood cells or antibodies
and so we're going to give you a bone
marrow transplant you've heard of people
who've been
given bone marrow transplants all they
had to do is get off of gluten
and get on the 90 essential nutrients a
healthy brain and heart pack or msm
vitamin d3 and some glucogel
and stay off all the bad foods and their
bone marrow would grow back
it's so simple dr wall like people just
don't understand
how it could work well that's because
their doctor says
oh just listen to me i'm your doctor
insurance will pay
it'll only cost you 500 000 for that
bone marrow transplant
but you don't have to pay the insurance
pays you know
listen to me i'll give you a double knee
replacement and you don't have to pay
fifty thousand dollars per knee but you
don't pay insurance pays
well if they would listen to me they
wouldn't have to have the surgery and
have the risk of dying
from the surgery now here's the
beautiful picture
there's been at least a dozen doctors in
the last six months
who would go get the vaccine and then
two to six weeks later they're dead
from the covet that's because they're
eating oatmeal for breakfast
flour tortillas for lunch drinking
whiskey at dinner time at night made
from wheat
their bone marrows are dead because
they're not taking any vitamins milk so
they could get everything they need by
eating well and then when they got the
vaccine they still got the
and then they jump in with all these
sick people i'm vaccinated i'm covered
they jump in with all these sick people
the virus kills them
right right so i i want to
go backwards just a little bit dr
wallace we're talking about how
plants only need three nutrients
nutrients that's correct
three nutrients to make them big and
beautiful and and
make seeds for the next generation
that's right
and if that mineral is not in the ground
plants cannot create their own minerals
it has to be
present in the ground that's correct now
here's a beautiful thing let's stop
there for a second
have you ever heard of bottom land or
flood plains yes
now when a family would buy or acquire
somehow
flood plains or bottomland for their
farm or the ranch would they ever
give it away or sell it never why
because every year when it would flood
the flood waters when it would recede
would leave
silt minerals from the mountains where
the river originated
and renew the soil every year okay well
out in the middle of missouri where
there's no
flood waters after five six seven years
the
land is depleted and they would either
have to move on
okay or they'd have to
start fertilizing their soil very
heavily so the plants would grow but if
they only fertilize with three minerals
they're still dying
now that's how i learned about it when i
was nine years old i had diseases nobody
knew
existed and um to make a long story
short i cured myself in three days
when 20 doctors couldn't fix it just by
eating animal food
that's how i got the idea when i was
dying that vitamins and minerals are
important
well this whole story of
the electricity and how it killed us
by eliminating wood stoves and wood
ashes in our in our life we have the cd
that
came out in 2003 we got the book that
came out in 2000
and five and um then we have black king
lies the book and
jean lies a cd and we have immortality
the book and the cd those three books
and those three cds
tell you what's going on here because we
didn't have
we we would have plagues every 20 30 40
50 years but they don't only last for a
couple of weeks
okay why are why uh in
1918 right after the um first world war
we had the spanish flu
20 million people from india died 20
million from people from india died in
six months
in that same six months we lost uh 957
thousand americans in october
of 1918 we lost 195 000 americans in
that one month
from the spanish flu wow and then
and then in 2003 came
h1n1 sars mers
and covid ii and
then 2005 it was worse and that's why i
came out with the books
to tell the story why they go into
when we gave up wood for fuel we gave up
our source of minerals which was our
food for our bone marrows to make white
blood cells antibodies protect us
against these terrible viruses
now you watch if people don't listen to
us
the next plague that comes the next
pandemic which could be
two months from now or two years from
now when it comes
it's gonna be a hundred times worse than
this one
okay because they keep getting worse and
worse and worse and worse
so you got to give up gluten no wheat no
brother in oats and live like an asian
live like the ojibwe indians live on
rice
live like the vietnamese live on rice
live on the um okinawans from the blue
zone live on rice well
people from say missouri don't have
access to seaweed
so we came out with what we call fucoid
seed which is
extracts of seaweeds and oceans gold
and originally we did it for thyroid
issues we were finding that people
who had dead bone marrow when they would
eat our
oceans gold and our fucoid z and our 90
and stay away from gluten
their bone marrow grew back and their
doctor says well these blood numbers
can't be right let's get
run some tests again they random against
it well i don't know why but you don't
have bone marrow problems anymore
you've had bone marrow problems for 20
years and suddenly now you don't have
anymore they walk out smiling because
they know
they gave up gluten and took the 90 and
they could absorb the 90 and rebuild
their bone marrow
and so um if the more and more people
who are listening to us
the more and more we're creating we're
creating a community which i call
the youngevity blue zone the youngevity
blue zone because we're in there with
okinawa
okay we're in there with um sardinia
italy okay we're in there with ikea
greece
we're in there with uh nicoya um
costa rica these are all part of the
blue zone system which is on the cover
cover story national geographic 2005.
these are the longest lived peoples on
earth
they have a common um lifestyle
they live on maize they call it the
three sisters all of them eight to three
sisters
are cannibals what do you mean they're
eating the three sisters they call the
three sisters
maize corn beans squash then they also
all ate seaweed because they all live
near the coast
all eat seaweed they're getting all
these weird trace minerals to feed their
bone marrows
and they boiled and steamed everything
because they didn't have any oil to deep
fry
and they didn't get introduced to wheat
for bread until
1860 by the scottish
and then that started a problem but the
problem really came
at three o'clock in the afternoon monday
september 4th 1882
when thomas edison and jonathan leaves
pulled the switch electricity and we
went away from wood ashes in our gardens
this is very simple and it's all written
up
in this book hell's kitchen and the cd
it's all written up in this book
black gene lies in the book and the cd
it's all written up
in the book the cd immortality and if
people will
give these as gifts you'll add 25 to 50
healthful years of people's lives
for the cost of a cup of coffee every
day
yeah that doesn't take much it's all all
goes to
uh you know
you have to push the right yeah you have
to you have to push the right button
you can take all the penicillin you can
take all this stuff
okay and what does it mean there's only
one
there's only one class of
pharmaceuticals that cure anything
as antibiotics can kill staphylococcus
streptococcus e coli salmon all that
kind of stuff
all other pharmaceuticals now watch my
lips here rebecca
all pharmaceuticals other than
antibiotics just treat symptoms
right when you have lupus doctors will
say oh you have an autoimmune disease
your body's
you know attacking itself so we're going
to give you prednisone cortisone in
three days time i mean that lupus pain
is gone your rash goes away
i love my doctor man i had this lupus
thing for 12 years he finally diagnosed
it
he gave me this drug and in three days
time was gone then two more years you're
dead
well it but lupus lupus lupus is a
gluten problem
and the rosacea you get is a deficiency
of a particular nutrient so
you get on the healthy branded hard pack
you get off of gluten
your lupus goes away in two weeks and
your doctor
should go to jail i think i have a cd
said only dead doctors don't lie yes i
have another cd says
your doctor should go to jail and we
have a new cd out just out
is your doctor killing you we list all
these diseases that doctors killed or
patients treating their patients with
drugs that don't work
ah well i am here to say supplementation
does work and i thank you dr wallach for
not giving up even when you've had so
many things coming at you trying to shut
you up
you didn't and i know myself and
i've seen many of the people that are on
this live call with
us want to thank you as well for
continuing this crusade and allowing us
to be able to be on this crusade with
you
well we thank you rebecca and all your
team and all the other people who are
associated with youngju who call it
you know our army and i knew um
back in 1982 i knew and i'm seeing this
in my passion i graduated from nature
pathetic college in
portland oregon it was uh ncnm national
college and naturopathic medicine now
they're in unm
national university and hispanic
medicine and i've been licensed in
portland oregon and oregon the state of
oregon since 1982 i've been licensed in
california since they started i think 12
years ago
my license number in oregon is 533 my
license number
in california is 61.
and i'm getting licensed in arizona
because we're going to be treating 23
tribes of pima indians
because they have 6 50 excuse me 46
almost
almost fifty percent have type two
diabetes
the pima indians in mexico only four
percent they're the same genetic
people but they only have four percent
diabetes and
in arizona and the people indian
reservation they have 46 percent now
what does that tell you
diet you get an a plus plus
posterior now medical doctors are
telling all these pm indians in the 23
tribes in arizona they have a genetic
disease
and they will need these medical doctors
and their and their insulin forever
i will i want to get rid of their
diabetes in two weeks
okay and so i'm in the process of
getting licensed and
probably by the middle of next month i
will be licensed in arizona
i'll be heading up there and living in a
wigwam
with with the pima indians and in two to
six weeks time
we will end the type 2 diabetes in the
pima indians
and there'll be hundreds of doctors who
go bankrupt
okay because they're living on these
pima indians like the pima indians or
milk cows
okay and all we have to do is get them
off of the gluten get them on the
healthy
blood sugar pack and it all will go
away yes it will
yes it will um so dr wallach we have
we have hands up we have several
people who have written in the chat
i have emails so let's go ahead
and get started let's do it
people's calls with their questions now
i just want you all to know
and the people that have their hands up
right now thank you so much for having
your cameras
on we appreciate that that allows dr
wallach to be able to
get a good look at you and get some
additional information
just by some of the the features that we
offer
that are very much contributed to
or by nutritional deficiencies
so first we're going to go to janet dr
wallick
janet go ahead and unmute yourself you
were on live with dr wallach
hello hello hi dr wallace uh i'm richard
you're not janet okay you're not janet
no no i
i i try to help you though uh let me
give you the statistics here
janet's weight is 132 pounds her height
is five
seven her age is 71. and the first
concern
is uh the possible causes for
hydrocephalus
she's now treating the symptoms with the
shunt that was implanted on march the
11th of last year
uh so that's one concern as to what okay
we'll stop there
okay stop there um let's see here um
janet do you have white gray or silver
hair
yes okay that's very important that's
very important
okay okay stop do you have any varicose
veins or spider veins in your legs
yes i do some like okay i sure do it's
kind of like being pregnant
either you is or you ain't and the
answer is yes
okay okay now uh do you have any
tinnitus or ringing in the ears
uh no do you have any dizziness or
vertigo or balance problems
no no okay are you graduating i have
everything else
i can tell you what i do have okay let
me ask you some specific questions first
do you have any okay do you have any
gradual loss of vision or you know are
you having to
get reading glasses and things where you
didn't have that before
um i i had one
eye on the right and that was
a cat no was it another cataract you had
an implant
they took that out okay
okay stop okay now do you have anything
going on in your hands any
tingling numbness your hands are burning
and your your
husband is shaking his head yes yes and
just last night she talked about her
hands like being on fire and she's done
that quite often uh
like a tingling uh hot sensation okay
now do you have any low back stuff for
any things going on in your feet you
know sciatica that kind of stuff
uh okay do you have any bowel problems
how many bowel problems constipation
diarrhea irritable syndrome crohn's
disease celiac disease
yes no we yeah
she's pretty although sometimes it's a
problem
okay the answer is yes okay a one word
answer yes
okay i don't need to know 18 years worth
of details i just want to know yes or no
okay do you have any skin pumps any
eczema dermatitis psoriasis or rosacea
he's shaking his head yes yes on the
face a little
my face a little yeah okay it's like
being pregnant a little
exactly okay now you have osteoporosis
of the skull and you have a gluten
problem
okay you need to get this book it's all
in your head
okay that's my my latest book there's
another one coming out here pretty soon
another book coming out but this one you
need to get okay
it's all in your head yeah well that's
good but this one goes specifically into
osteoporosis of the skull and all the 25
different diseases you've got like five
of them
okay you got five of the 25 different
diseases you can get from osteoporosis
skulls you need to get that book it's on
your head
did your doctor tell you had
osteoporosis of the skull
he didn't know what no no no just yes or
no
no no you need to immediately change
doctors
because half of your problems are due to
osteoporosis of the skull
okay so here we go do you have any
highlight pressure or diabetes
no okay so here's what i want you to do
get rid of all the bad foods no fried
foods no processed meats no oils no
glutens or wheat bran oats
your husband has to do the same thing
yeah
but the big question is uh is is coconut
oil considered oil as well
oil is oil well no coconut oil
okay no oil okay you said it thank you
do you speak english uh somewhat
okay
we have to help each other like can't i
have oats
i'm getting gluten-free oats you're dead
because there is no such thing as
gluten-free oats
people who sell oats yeah what you want
to do is box up all your oats and your
wheaties and
all that kind of stuff and you're
cooking it all and give it to your
doctor with love just like remember that
double07 movie to russia with love you
want to give
everything that you're going to get rid
of don't throw it away
it'll be if you're a younger associate
one of our distributors
you'll get a tax uh break by giving
all that stuff to your doctor as a
sample
okay and write on the cost off as a tax
break
okay and it's to your doctor with love
just like you know double
seven gave to russia with love okay
you do not want to take those things
anymore because we need to regrow your
villa your hair color will come back
your varicose veins will go away your
skin problems will go away
all your other problems will go away the
odds are
you have at least five different
diseases um i have to ask you one more
thing anything going on with your heart
any
um fast heart rate um
things like um uh afib slow heart rate
bradycardia anything like that high
blood pressure
no not when we take our plat
no not when you take your medicine
we're on no we're on the only thing she
said is the doctor would like uh
um methocarbamol and and uh get a new
doctor
get a new doctor yeah okay good
she started 12 16 of last year the
healthy bone body and joint pack and
she's on her second cycle now
okay good now she needs to also throw in
and this is what's going to make her
hair
color come back and her varicose veins
go away okay
she needs to switch over from the
healthy bone and joint pack she needs to
switch over to the healthy brain and
heart pack
and i want to take a full dose i want
her to take a full
half a dose of everything twice a day
except for our selenium i want you to
get another bottle of our selenium
because our selenium has a stuff and it
has five cofactors one of which is
what's missing is why you have the gray
hair in the varicose veins
and so i want you to take three of our
selenium are selenium at walgreens
selenium our slam has the cofactors
okay five it or excuse me three
breakfast three dinner time so you need
to get another bottle of that because
one bottle will come with the health or
banana hard pack
then i want you to keep taking the msm
take msm take three of those
twice today it'll rebuild your skull
your disc between your vertebrae
and your skin and let's see here
um i also want you to take
because you have some of fluid in the
brain but that's being caused
because that place where your spinal
cord is coming out of your skull
is squeezing your spinal cord and is not
letting
the fluid that's producing your brain
circulate once that
skull begins to heal and that opens up
you won't have hydrocephalus
of the brain anymore okay i'm aching i'm
i'm all the time it's okay that's what
the msm is for
that was in the advanced multi uh
multi-level cervical spondylosis which
she had a
steroid injection back in august the
14th last year
so that'll address that problem as well
that's correct yeah exactly
all those things are nutritional
deficiencies your doctors are giving all
these
miracle medications right these doctors
need to go to jail
okay thank you so give us a call
everything
give us a call every two weeks and give
us a progress report because your
testimony is going to save millions of
people thank you janet thank you
champion
do you have a number we can call just to
verify everything that she wants to take
you know what you're know what you're
going to do is you're going to go
because rebecca is going to post this
and so you can come back on
and read it because i'm not going to
repeat everything okay great okay
okay okay rebecca let's go to the next
one yeah to
livestocklive.com and we will have the
recording of
this meeting including all the ones from
the past will be
on askdoclive.com all right
so thank you so much janet um
next let's go to is it imo
amo go ahead and unmute yourself
is it emma yeah i'm you got that right
i'm old how'd you do
all right great thanks greetings from uh
from ojibwe country
northern uh minnesota minnesota we're
just north of the minnesota border
okay okay if you're a canadian so you
have white hair i see that
yeah you're right um i'm staying off all
the bad stuff i'm five foot ten
i'm 180 pounds but i have what they call
deportance contracture
i don't know okay duper yeah duper
trains contractor i know it
okay hold up your hand
okay yeah there you go what is in both
hands or just the right one
that's my right hand that's yeah i know
that but i mean does do you have duper
change contraction in both hands or just
in your right hand
just in the right one and i think i had
uh trauma on it first
no okay anything going on in your feet
and your legs
um on my left the left toe the big
big toe joint has a little bit of uh
i don't know if it's arthritis or
swelling or whatever but it's bigger on
my left
okay now okay are you in ojibwe or
cherokee or
no i don't even know how to find any
wild rice
well we need to go up to the lakes or
down to the lakes
okay do you have anything else any habit
pressure diabetes
no okay no arthritis
uh no other than my big toe i don't know
what that is
yeah okay well duper trains contracture
um
is kind of like you've heard of sciatica
where people get low back stuff and they
get numbness and pain and burning their
feet
well duper trains contracture is the
equivalent thing because you've got
stuff going on in your
neck um and your arms and that's
why your hand has that kind of thing the
nerves are being squeezed up in your
neck
and your upper back do you have any
ringing in your ears any tinnitus or
tone in your ears
any vertigo or balance problems no but i
don't have the neck problem because i
had an injury
yeah always everybody blames it on an
injury okay all right so here we go
and you weigh 180 pounds you say
yeah okay none of the bad foods
absolutely no fried foods no processed
meats no oils no glutens and wheat bread
around notes no sugar
everybody in your household dog cat bird
fish spouse partner roommate caregiver
what kind of work do you do i'm retired
now
how old are you i'm uh 65.
okay all right i'm hearing
a big echo rebecca yeah i'm here too dr
wallach i'm trying to find it
thank you canada oh okay
okay all right so i need to get
in there again this is for our listening
audience here you need to get rid of the
bad stuff no fried foods no processed
meats no oils no glutens no wheat bread
right now no sugar and i know
um canada's a big wheat growing country
yeah because i i
lecture a lot up in canada i love our
canadian brothers and sisters i go up
there a lot
and i have some great stories but not
today so any rate
additionally to get off all the bad
foods at 180 pounds i want you to take
two healthy brain and heart packs per
month
two healthy brain and heart pattern up
the full dose everything twice a day
i want you to get two bottles a month of
our msm so you can take three with each
meal
take three breakfast three at lunch at
dinner time and then
um i want you also to take our vitamin
d3 take three of those
twice a day there's two bottles a month
i want you to take our
uh glucogel take two bottles a month if
you want the capsules and take five with
each meal
if you prefer the liquid you can take
three quarts a month of the liquid take
an ounce with each meal
and then um let's see here
do you have any pain or anything in that
finger in the toe or
do you have any pain uh no just just a
little bit in my hand when i stretch it
yeah okay all right so let's go with
that and call us every two weeks because
you're gonna have a great testimony i
want you to take a picture
with your cell phone or have somebody
take a picture of you no of your hand
and also of your hair color
because if you do what i told you that
hair color will come back
even varicose veins and hemorrhoids and
spider veins all that kind of stuff goes
away
because those are all due to i don't
call them hemorrhoids they call them i
call them asteroids
okay you call them asteroids yeah okay
yeah but those things go away um because
the same thing causes asteroids
and hemorrhoids has caused the gray hair
okay the same
same deficiency but that'll all go away
when you do what i just told you
and let's hear from you every couple of
weeks is that emo imo
imo okay imo god bless all of the best
we love you canadians thank you so much
right all right so dr wellick we have
marty
that wrote in the comments and he had
called in about six weeks ago
you had recommended the herbal
rainforest for constipation he said it's
great
[Laughter]
um and he's also taking the 90 essential
nutrients
now he is a diet type 2 diabetic
and he noticed that his blood sugar went
up what he
what can he take dr wallach to help
counteract that
okay he needs more of these sweeties uh
he needs to take three of our sweeties
twice a day per 100 pounds of body
weight so he weighs 150 pounds he needs
three sweeties at breakfast lunch and
dinner
so that'll be three bottles a month and
he needs to consciously
stay away from sugar he can have you
know
start out with a tablespoon of rice and
a tablespoon of sweet potatoes
he can have eggs he can have red meat he
can have fish all that kind of stuff
all the vegetables he wants but he's got
to stay away from fruit and fruit juices
and stuff like that to begin with
but he'll get plenty of vitamin c and
that kind of thing from green leafy
vegetables
and so forth okay for salad dressings
he can use lemon juice squeeze the lemon
or
lime on his salad or he can go to our
savory division our
division of our all of our spices and
that kind of stuff
we have safe oil-free and sugar-free
salad dressings and things along with he
also needs to take some
of our pink himalayan salt has 84
minerals in it
and i take the pink himalayan salt i
just had some of my three scoops of
wild rice this morning for breakfast and
at dinner time i'll have our pink
himalayan salt with a black ground
pepper in it
okay so a little variation on my sweet
potatoes with butter
along with my steak okay and then three
nights a week
i have pizza what yeah i have pizza but
it's made the crust is made from
cauliflower so it's gluten-free
there you go there you go they're
getting very creative
dr wallick but you have to ask for you
have to say i want the cauliflower
gluten-free pizza crust
and costco's that's where i get it from
i get it from costco's
and i'll get three fresh ones and i get
about 10
frozen ones because there's snow and
stuff here like right now you see i'm
wearing a hoodie because it's like 40
degrees here
in southern california this time of year
should be 80 degrees it's 40 degrees
and i've got four shirts on and a hoodie
oh goodness so now we were talking about
rice
and uchi wants to know um which
type of rice and somebody else had
mentioned something about
leptins um and wondering if
okay here's here's the answer to that
question rebecca
um you can have any type of rice you
want except fried rice
because you're heating oils that's the
worst possible thing you do that's going
to give you cancer and block your
arteries
no fried rice this morning i had wild
rice
for breakfast now this afternoon this
evening if i have rice instead of sweet
potatoes
i'll have brown rice white rice
yellow rice red rice pink rice it
doesn't matter as long as it's not fried
okay i do not depend on rice for any
nutrition other than just calories and
filler and that kind of stuff
okay but what i do do is i take three
of our fucoid z capsules twice a day
which is made out of
15 different seaweeds okay and i also
take three of our oceans gold twice a
day
but like you don't have a thyroid plum
do you know but i want the seaweeds
for my bone marrow okay i want the
seaweeds
okay from the fucoid z for my bone
marrow now i'm 82 years old
and most people think that i'm in my 50s
when they look at me or early 60s
okay and i'm as old as hank aaron who
just died
okay great baseball player one of my
heroes okay
i was sad that he died and um
because i'm i'm his age and i look 25
years younger than him
right okay and so it's one of those
things where if if you
eat rice it's fine it just cannot be
fried rice could be again
wild rice brown rice and now this all
goes back
to again 1860 when the scottish came and
converted
all of the native americans from eating
the three sisters the maize corn
beans and squash and whatever
wild um acorns and
onions and things like that they could
find okay
they converted them over to wheat and
the deep fried bread they call bannock
it says flat bread they deep fry called
bannock and that started
all the native americans downhill and
that's why at three o'clock in the
afternoons
monday september 4th 1882 the native
americans were hit hard the latinos were
hit hard the black people were hit hard
because they're eating gluten and they
took away their minerals when they took
away their wood ashes and gave them
electricity
and that was a double hit no minerals
okay
and they're eating gluten now whereas
the ojibwes up in northern minnesota
and also in central and eastern
canada they live on wild rice no gluten
in rice they live like asians and so
that's why
the ojibwe indians have zero dead and 27
infected same population as the navajo
indians in arizona who live on
wheat okay and
they live on wheat both beer oatmeal
bread spaghetti flour tortillas
and they have 858 dead versus zero dead
and in the in the ojibwe indians they
have 24
000 infections versus 27 infections same
population
it's just totally died has nothing to do
with we're comparing here native
americans with native americans
when i first started talking about this
i'm saying you know the latin
the native americans have the highest
rate
of death per hundred thousand and
everybody's saying well it's a genetic
thing
no well the blacks are the second no
it's a not a genetic thing
it's their diet the polynesians oh we're
talking about
um the um hawaiians and so forth the
people
the various islands okay that eat a lot
of
wheat they're next the latinos from
mexico and spain
they're next the whites are next but the
asians are very low because they live on
rice and
seaweed and sweet potatoes and the three
sisters
okay so that's why that differential
is and um like i say i have another
book coming out with miss linda coming
out here pretty soon
um it's called the the greatest stories
ever told not the greatest story ever
told that's the bible
right okay this is the greatest stories
ever told the subtitle is
millions of healing miracles
i can't wait now when you read this book
it's going to blow your mind
because we're setting it up as a
supplement
to the old testament the new testament
and the
quran okay so we didn't have to write a
whole series
of encyclopedias to deal with this we're
just going to go into all these
different
literally millions of testimonies we
would take
ten thousand testimonies on one disease
and we would kind of summarize it into
maybe the hundred most
dynamic you understand what i'm saying
so we didn't have to have
a a an encyclopedia britannica set with
25 books and everything in it
it was we're trying to figure out how to
do this so he figured out how to make a
summaries of different diseases
and it's going to be a supplement to the
old testament the new testament and the
quran
and so we're so excited about this we're
like 90 done with it and miss linda has
been working day and night for a year on
this
so we're very excited and it's coming
soon
linda's incredible she she's one of my
inspirations i just love her to death
well thank you for that i'm sure she's
listening and watching
well dr wellick it's at the top of the
hour so let's go ahead and take
five and everybody stay where you're
at keep your hands raised we do address
those in the order that they
were raised and we will be right
back with askdoc live
all right thank you everybody for
sticking with us during that
short break um again
if you um well i haven't said it yet so
let's not go again
but if you were shared this program
by somebody you want to make sure that
you get with the person that share this
program with you
they have an interest in you because
you're either a friend
family member and they care about you so
they share this information
and they show with you so that you can
make sure
you get information that is not
commonly shared and
from experience myself and working with
clients
we get people on the good foods bad
foods list we start the supplementation
and it's like they're reborn
just really finding better health with
less pain
and i always thought that you know
growing old
pain was normal getting blood sugar
issues
normal blood pressure issues normal
um because i had all of those things
when i was 30 but now that i'm 50 i
don't have any of them
so i encourage all of you to really pay
attention because it's
it's fabulous not hurting
not having to take pharmaceuticals it
it's a it's a good thing and i want
everybody to be able to experience that
so absolutely so we're going to wait for
dr wallach to get back
on with us um if you have never
purchased any of the products that dr
wallach is mentioning today
and you were not invited to this program
by somebody specifically you can go to
askdoclive.com
and you will find a store with all of
the products that we're mentioning here
we also have a call team that is
standing by
at eight five five nine four
nine radio that's eight five five
nine four nine seven two
three four again that's if you have
never
ordered products before and you're
interested in talking with one of the
uh health coaches that are at that line
they are there for you if you
have spoken or if you have tried the
products before
you want to make sure that you get with
the person that you spoke with that
helped you figure out what that
protocol was or the products that you
ordered
you can also call 800-982-3189 to read
our reach our corporate office
if you need help in reordering now dr
wallach are you ready to go i'm back
awesome awesome because marco is here
with his hand raised
marco you are on live with dr wallach go
ahead and unmute yourself
hello hello marco yes
dr wallach i'm pretty much healthy i'm
45 years old
i'm 6 feet tall i'm 163 pounds i eat
well
no gluten i jog three times a week
and i started to having pain on my knees
i also feeling that i'm lacking energy i
feel tired easily
i feel that my vision is not uh sharp as
it used to be
and also i started to have in uh
gray air on the sides okay now
let's see where are you from you have an
accent are you russian yeah no i'm from
uh
florence italy italy oh okay
bon giorno bonjour
[Laughter]
okay yeah all right do you have any like
tone or ringing in your ears you have a
noise any balance problems no
any dry skin no okay what about bowel
problems constipation diarrhea anything
like that
no okay excellently now italians eat
more gluten than anybody else
yes yes spaghetti yeah
i've been on a gluten-free dry diet
for about six months okay excellent
since uh december i also cut off the
olive oil
excellente okay very good now you should
be feeling better just by getting rid of
the bad stuff
yeah okay so here we go and now since
you've started all that i'm going to
sell this anyway for the rest of our
audience
absolutely no bad foods no fried foods
no processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat broth
oats no sugar you can have pizza but
it's got to be gluten-free pizza crust
right
okay you can have noodles but they got
to be rice noodles
you can have chicken rice soup you can't
have chicken noodle soup
you know you have to pay attention to
those details you can have
rice bread and cornbread but no italian
bread
okay and again just for our
listeners real quick uh let's look at
the i think i have italy on here
oh yeah let's look at italy they have 60
million people 60 million people
they have two and a half million
infections
and 86 000 dead
86 000 dead in less than a year in italy
because
of the pandemic virus 86 000
dead now i have to look up i'll find out
how many people
died in italy in the second world war
compare i'll find that out really
quickly so
uh next friday i will have that for us
it's
86 000 dead in italy
from from the pandemic and that's
because they're eating gluten their
intestines are dead
and do all italians eat seaweed or just
some
i would say that all of them all
all of them eat a little bit of seaweed
yeah okay good
excellent so they're getting some trace
minerals okay
so again uh you know you look at
an equivalent population uh from
um i'm trying to find out here really
quickly equivalent population did
i don't find an equivalent population i
have one
from the uk they're just as bad in the
uk yes
okay okay let's look at thailand okay
let's look at thailand
thailand uh has 66 million people
okay thailand has 66 million people
italy has 60 million
thailand has um
let's see here thailand has 13 000
infections and 75
dead and they have six more million
people in italy
okay and they have 13 000 14 000
infections versus 2.5 million infections
in italy
that's the difference see in thailand
they live on rice and sweet potatoes
and beans and squash and seaweed in
italy it's wheat
wheat wheat and wheat okay
so that's why the huge difference in
infections and deaths
okay so um
i want you to get rid of and again you
know a lot of this but this is for the
rest of our listening audience marco
uh no fried foods no processed meats
oils or gluten so we brought around oats
and at 163 pounds i want you to have two
healthy brain and heart packs a month
that's our big hammer in the toolbox
um two healthy brain heart pasture month
of full dose shifting twice a day
i want you also to take the
and where do you live right now
in miami florida okay miami okay
so i want you to um uh also take
two bottles a month of our msm after a
while it cuts you down to one bottle a
month but i want you to start out with
two bottles a month at the msm
so you can take um let's see here
three with each meal that's going to
help you rebuild your cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between vertebrae bone matrix bone
itself and the knees and
every place else your skull and so on i
also want you to take our vitamin d3
take three of those twice it has two
bottles a month vitamin d3
even if you live in miami you don't get
naked and lay out in the sun for four
hours a day you usually sit in the shade
you know most people
they live in a sunny place like florida
and california and hawaii
they sit in the shade i find that funny
okay okay
um but also for your knees i want you to
get the
um gluco gel you can get two bottles a
month to the capsules take
five of those with each meal or you
could take five twice a day
and then get our collagen peptides which
are collagen from
fish poultry sheep and cattle and take a
dose of that at noon time
and for the energy thing i want you to
get our rebound our sports drink
has 100 nutrients and we built that for
professional athletes and olympic
athletes and
we actually built it for theo ratliff
the basketball player who'd lost all his
contracts because of fractures and joint
problems and everything
we rebuilt him with a healthy bone and
joint pack and threw in
and we made the rebound for him and he
got a 35 million dollar contract so you
know it works
okay and then because you're getting
some vision issues
i think it's because of the osteoporosis
in the skull
okay squeezing the optic nerve it's
called ona optic nerve atrophy
and so if you want to you can take
something for your eyes we call it
vision fx you can take three of those
twice a day and
but doing all this other stuff is going
to take the pressure off the optic nerve
and rebuild the skull and call us every
two weeks marco because you have at your
age
a very common set of problems that
afflict many many people and they're
going to appreciate your testimony and
so you'll help a lot of people okay
so if you'll call us every two weeks and
give us a status report
and if you go to a doctor and get any
kind of comment from them
uh then you can tell us that too okay
okay can i ask something for my wife
the info yes yes okay she's 49
127 pounds she's 5.5
feet tall she has spider veins
she has hemorrhoids and she also has
pain in the knees
because she worked as a waitress so she
she worked a lot
does she have gray or white hair yes she
does
okay well the same thing same deficiency
that causes gray hair it's not age
she's only 49 years old so white hair
i mean i see teenagers with white hair
like michael jackson he was a black kid
he had snow white hair by the time he
was 18 years old
he had vitiligo he was as snow white as
typing paper
because he lost the ability to make skin
color and hair color and he died of a
ruptured aneurysm
okay which is caused by the same
deficiency okay so you're headed that
direction
she's headed that direction if she
doesn't do something so
at 127 pounds you say yes
okay she needs to get rid of all the bad
foods so if
you guys will be eating the same no
fried foods no processed meats no oils
no glutens no wheat broth rhinos or
sugar
127 pounds i want her to get one healthy
brain and heart pack per month
but i also want her to get another
bottle of sleep so she can take three of
those twice a day because
one bottle comes the slim comes with
that and
the our selenium has five cofactors in
there one of which
is the thing that's missing to give you
hemorrhoids
varicose veins spider veins white hair
and also your cartilage going away and
all that kind of stuff
right and so um so she needs to take
three of those
uh selenium twice a day and then i also
wanted to have the msm get her one
bottle a month in the msm so you take
three twice a day
and um i want her to take um
vitamin d3 three of those twice a day
and um let's see here
does she have anything else any high
blood pressure diabetes no
no no okay well let's go with that and
then call us every couple of weeks and
give us a testimony for both her
and yourself uh so neither of you have
any diabetes
no okay great okay okay but
where can i get your cds and your books
okay you get my cds and books um
let's see here uh i'll give you a a
website
and rebecca's gonna give you a website
good thank you okay
my website is www.drjwalik.com all
lowercase www.drjwalik.com
and then uh you would if you would uh
rebecca you know give
um marco your website also
and i will say arrivederci
thank you awesome thank you so much
um so housedoclive.com
we do have a
mostly dr wallach's most popular books
so okay do you have the cds and we
i believe we have a couple cds as well
okay well i have
a hundred cds right now you have 50 dvds
we have um
15 best selling books we have another
one coming out here pretty soon
my newest cds are is your doctor killing
you
okay and also the red warning light goes
into the sort of eight pre-existing
conditions
caused by nutritional deficiencies
secondary to gluten consumption
it sets you up for a bad outcome from
the pandemic virus
okay and then it's called the red
warning light and then dr milan and i
are working on another one
with scott ferdulis this one is called
the manchurian the manchurian
prescription
are you old enough to remember the book
in the movie the manchurian candidate
not old enough but i have heard about it
okay well just briefly
the mancurian candidate the book and and
and the movie
were about two american um soldiers one
officer the other one was a sergeant who
were captured during the vietnam war
okay or was the korean korean war excuse
me the korean war and
they were brainwashed for the two years
there in prison when the war was over
they were sent back the united states
all the other prisoners
but they were unwittingly because they
were brainwashed for two years
in the in the north korean prison
they were unwittingly working as agents
for the north koreans
so we're calling this cd
the manchurian prescription because it
goes into all the things
that fauci told us to do to protect
ourselves from the pandemic virus
okay wear a mask distance yourself
six feet apart wash your hands and
everything will be fine
you know it's not a big deal and what
did we get for that
right now we are at 25 million
556 000 infections 435
241 dead does that sound like a nothing
that sounds like somebody um is giving
the wrong information dr wallach
yeah well that's why we um came up with
that title for this cd set
and what it was was i i gave a zoom
lecture
to eight um asian countries
okay and we had a translator so i would
speak for three or four minutes the
translator was translated into mandarin
the main chinese language you can hear
them in the background translating into
korean and
vietnamese and all kind of stuff but
it's a beautiful
cd it's called the manchurian
prescription and that will be out
pretty soon here and i want everybody to
remember
that they can
utilize this to go to the
asian community the newspapers the
magazines the radio the tv stations
chinatown and every city right
and so here's a tool that you're going
to be able to communicate with these
people and get the information to them
because the asian communities that live
on rice and sweet potatoes and corn and
seaweed
if they get the pandemic virus they do
very well
if they eat a western style diet and
live on wheat parlor in oats
they're dead so that's why we call it
the manchurian prescription
all right well i look forward to another
great book coming out
from you dr wallick and dr malan as well
um let's go to uh the gentleman
it's labeled as lg stylo5 so i've tried
to get his attention to get his name
because i like to
introduce people by their name but if
you could unmute yourself you were on
live with dr wallach
thank you thank you i'm sorry it's ron
loose l-u-c-e thank you ron
thank you rob thank you doctor i'm glad
i got
on here today i'm gonna help you i'm 230
pounds i'm 6'5
i'm 67 i've been diagnosed recently
it's been happening eight years now once
a year once a quarter
i would get these uh syncope episodes
but now
i've got a serious problem i went to the
hospital for four days
i think they misdiagnosed it with uh i
think it's uh
super venticular tachycardia but they
said afib
and gave me all kinds of stuff okay okay
stop there a minute okay stop a minute
okay stop a minute
okay um now you have white hair
now do you have varicose veins in your
legs yes sir
okay i knew that because the same thing
that causes
gray hair the same deficiency that comes
great here it's not an age thing it's a
deficiency
causes varicose veins and spider veins
and also hemorrhoids
now uh when you have afib
it's it's not a heart problem when you
have afib it's not a heart problem now
do you have any ringing in your ears any
tone or tinnitus
no okay do you have any balance problems
any vertigo or dizziness
well only when i'm having i have about
five to seven
uh dizzy spells which when my heart's
racing at night
yes the answer is yes with a hundred and
eighty eight hundred yeah i don't
i don't need all that i just yes or no
and the answer is yes okay a little bit
yes okay yes
are you pregnant well we had sex six
months ago and now
you know we travel around and i had a
whole you know i had a pregnancy test
i i just need yes or no okay
okay afib is actually osteoporosis of
the skulls
squeezing the 10th cranial nerve the
vagus nerve do you have any belly
problems any bloating or
gas or belching or burping or hiccups or
anything like that
yes or no no i've got two more issues i
was going to tell you but go ahead oh
okay do you have diabetes or have a
pressure
no do you have any arthritis yes
okay well that goes along with the afib
because when you have osteoporosis of
the skull it squeezes the 10th cranial
nerve
that's what causes afib and where
what state do you live in california
okay palm springs okay
very good all right
so did you have anything else you wanted
to talk about just tell me the disease
severe peripheral neuropathy about 60
loss of body strength and a tumor on my
pituitary gland that's about 13
millimeters it's been there since 2015
and
growing very slowly it's a non-cancerous
tumor
by the way and then i have this
osteoarthritis in my
shoulders that hurt i can't even tear my
covers off my
okay stop stop that's because your skull
is squeezing your spinal cord as it's
coming out of your skull
yeah okay it used to be called herbs
palsy now it's called wallach's palsy
because herb thought it was a genetic
thing
because it happened in families but it's
actually just osteoporosis of the skull
so here we go
and you're six foot five did you play
basketball
everybody asked i i i was a tight end uh
in on football i couldn't just be
beautiful
well six foot five you don't need to
jump i'm only five foot six i
i need to drum okay well here we go
absolutely no bad foods no fried foods
no processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat broth right now so sugar
then i want you to have two healthy
brain and heart packs per month
two healthy brain and heart paths per
month full dose everything twice a day
i also want you to have our msm get two
bottles a month for that so you can take
three with each meal that's gonna help
you rebuild
your cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disc between the
vertebrae
bone matrix bone itself and then i want
you to get our vitamin d3 take three of
those twice a day
that's two bowels a month um and then i
also want you to take
our glucogel get two bottles of the
capsules take five
of those three times a day and then um
let's see here i want you also to take
the ultimate daily classic tablets take
three of those
um three times a day it'll be two uh
three bottles a month of the ultimate
daily classic talents take three
three times a day and that's going to
support and promote healthy blood flow
through blocked arteries in your brain
your eyes your heart
your legs your kidneys and all that kind
of stuff support healthy blood
pressure and so on you'll you'll lose a
few pounds
okay and also this afib is going to go
away very quickly
do not let them talk you into doing an
ablation don't let them do an ablation
which is where they kill part of your
heart muscle don't do that
they did that to um
let's see here the the um uh
representative the us representative
from baltimore maryland
um and they talked him into doing an
ablation
elijah elijah cummings cummings thank
you
elijah cummings yeah elijah cummings
and they did the ablation on him and
killed him during the surgery
they killed they killed a u.s
representative with an incorrect
treatment
and they got a walk this was johns
hopkins killed him
okay so anyway don't do that do what i
say and then call us every two weeks
you're gonna have a great testimony
um you'll have a great testimony here
for us and
um uh let's see here this lg whatever
did you did you work with uh rockets in
the military
uh it's just something that the phone
pops up on it's uh no
i did not okay okay well let's hear from
you every two weeks and
if you go to the doctor anymore he's
gonna say we need to rerun some tests
because this can't be right because this
shows you don't have this anymore that
anymore
and just let them rerun the test because
insurance will pay for it
but don't let them do any treatment for
the afib no treatment for afib
and five or six times a day i get the
188 to 191 heart
beat should i keep on their stupid
medication
okay well um you go ahead with your
okay but that's called tachycardia okay
we have a
and when you have a a rampant heart rate
okay and so what i want you to do is
stay on that but
take your pulse and as your pulse begins
to drop you can slowly
drop the medication bit by bit by bit
don't cold turkey off of it when you
start our supplement program
okay okay okay keep a good record
okay love you brother and let's hear
from me every couple of weeks okay
rebecca thank you very much yes sir
all right so dr warlick i have an email
that's coming in from
joseph and it it's amazing that
high level of emails and questions that
we get that have to do with an enlarged
prostate
so let me take a guess it only happens
in men
um yeah my questions are all from men or
their wives
[Laughter]
um but joseph says he's 84 years old and
in excellent health and he's wondering
what you would recommend
for his enlarged prostate he has to get
up six to eight times
each night to urinate um and during the
day
he must be near a a restroom because he
can't hold it very long
he's had two procedures dr wallach um
one of them he says was microwaved at
three years ago
and a live steam shot last year
now why would anybody put their prostate
gland in a microwave
i find that interesting okay well if i
had one i still wouldn't
okay do we know how much this guy weighs
175.
okay did you say anything about high
blood pressure diabetes he did not say
anything about
either of those okay okay well 84 years
old i guarantee he has some other issues
other than prostate
okay but he probably thinks well i've
got my medicine for my blood pressure i
got my medicine for my diabetes i'm okay
but anyway uh but he's 175 pounds
and so let's go with none of the bad
foods no fried foods no processed meats
no oils no glutens no we brought around
oats his spouse and dog and cat bird and
fish and caregiver and kids and
grandkids and
roommates and renters and everybody else
got to be gluten-free also
then at 175 pounds i wanted to take two
healthy brain and heart packs per month
the heavy hammer out of the toolbox two
healthy brain and heart packs for a
month to full dose everything twice a
day
i want him to get our msm get um two
bottles of msm a month so we take three
with each meal
and that's going to deal with cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue even
in the prostate and so forth
i also want him to take our vitamin d3
three of those twice a day
i want him also to take our sarah test
zara test i wanted to take three of
those twice it has two bottles a month
that's going to give his sertoli cells
and his testicles
what they need to make um testosterone
testosterone is 95
by weight cholesterol so he needs to eat
three eggs twice a day if he's on statin
drugs he's got to come off the statin
drugs
okay and then i want him to get three
bottles a month
of our frost fx you can take three of
those with each meal
i also want them to get two bottles a
month of our fucoids eat and take three
of those twice a day
and two bottles a month of our oceans
gold and take three of those twice a day
and then call us don't forget the eggs
three three two three twice a day
and call us every two weeks and let us
know how his prostate doing
and also when you respond to him ask him
what other issues does he have does he
have
diabetes hybrid pressure arthritis bowel
problem skin problems
ringing in his ears you know we want to
know all that kind of stuff so we know
how to rate how he's doing
okay absolutely thank you so much and
again i just want to let everybody know
that if you were invited to this program
by somebody it's because they care about
you
so make sure that you get back with them
if you have any questions and if you
would like to order any of the products
that dr wallach
is referring to today
if you um just found this program
because you're part of our newsletter
you can always respond back to that
email that you received inviting you to
this program with your questions
or you can also go to askdoclive.com
and we have a store there we have a
contact us
and that is available for you as well
so next let's go to
um leslie leslie go ahead and unmute
yourself
hello good afternoon yes sir how can we
help you
yes um i had kidney failure and i was on
dialysis for a couple of years
um i got a transplant and now i'm um
i'm transplanted and i'm on
anti-rejection medication
i have high blood pressure ring in your
ears and some dizziness
and a degenerative disc
okay how much do you weigh uh 194 pounds
how old are you sir 58
was that 58 5 8 5 eight
okay and you say have high blood
pressure
diabetes right no diabetes but how about
yes okay
now you're not on dialysis right now no
okay how long ago was your transplant uh
about ten and a half years ago okay
all right um
everything you have is a nutritional
deficiency disease now when you had
when you still had your kidneys there
was nothing wrong with your kidneys
okay what was happening was the arteries
taking the dirty blood and the kidneys
were blocked
and so your kidneys the blood test would
show your kidneys weren't filtering the
blood
because they weren't getting the dirty
blood because the arteries are blocked
okay your arteries are still blocked
that's why you have high pressure
okay okay so do you have any other
issues
and you have ringing in the ears you're
dizzy yeah but i do have ringing in the
ears
tinnitus tinnitus okay it's called um i
have
um problems with my eyes from time to
time where
i lose vision and the vision comes back
yeah
okay that's the osteoporosis of the
skull squeezing the optic nerve is
called o-n-a
optic nerve atrophy okay it's the same
things causing the dizziness and ringing
in the ears
okay i i do have osteopenia
well i wouldn't be surprised because
osteopenia is osteoporosis of your other
bones in your body
osteoporosis of the skull okay uh used
to be called paget's disease and now
it's called wallex disease because paget
thought it was a
a genetic thing because people get in
the families right it's really
just a nutritional decision so it's
called wallex disease now did they tell
you might have pageants disease
no they didn't i you know i started
having the ostopinia
when i started on my regimen and i was
taking prednisone
oh well that'll do it if you were on the
fence that'll kick you off the fence
onto the wrong side of the fence
absolutely okay i apologize you 194
pounds that correct
that's correct okay well here we go
five foot seven i have i have oh i got
five foot eight i apologize
58 i'm 58 and five foot seven
oh okay five foot seven and 58 years old
all right there we go now we got it
all right um so here we go
not analysis anymore no okay
i want you to get off all the bad foods
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens no wheat bryan oats
okay and then no sugar i also want you
to
um get on two healthy brain and heart
packs per month
two healthy brain and heart pressure
about the full dose filling twice a day
i want you to get two bottles a month of
our ultimate daily classic tablets take
three of those twice a day that's going
to support
healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries in your brain your heart your
kidneys and your legs everywhere else
but also it's going to support
healthy blood pressure so your blood
pressure is going to problems going to
go away
okay then i want you to take the msm
msm i want you to get two bottles of our
msm per month so you can take three with
each meal
that's going to help you rebuild your
disc you'll actually you'll
gain about anywhere from a half an inch
to two inches in height you're gonna
you're gonna grow because you're gonna
rebuild your disc take the pressure off
the disc
it's going to take away some of the
numbness and tangling in your hands and
feet and things like that
sciatica stuff going on in your hands
carpal tunnel syndrome which really it
isn't it's your skull squeezing your
spinal cord is coming out of the back
your skull
causing all that problem okay
um so yeah then i want you to
also take because you do have eye stuff
going on you get her
you can get her oh let's go with the
um um um let's let's go with the fucoid
z
three of those twice a day a few quite z
okay
that's that's our algae stuff with all
the weird trace minerals in it
uh for your bone marrow and then i also
want you to get our oceans gold three of
those twice as two pounds a month again
weird
um algae for your bone marrow so you
won't have
uh problems there okay and you gotta
stay away from the bad foods no fried
foods no processed meats oils so glutens
we brought around oats
and call us every two weeks you know
with your numbers how much you weigh
how tall you are and if you go to the
doctor for anything
we want to know what they say because
they're going to freak out okay
don't cold turkey off of any medication
if you're on medication for the
blood pressure uh just take your own
blood pressure you know
every day or every couple of days and as
it begins to slowly come down you can
slowly
reduce the medication bit by bit don't
cold turkey off your medication
two questions um one um
is this gonna do any harm to me because
i'm on these anti-rejections
attack um tacro uh myfordic
no okay this will not interfere with any
anti-rejection medication in fact it'll
make them work better
okay i i still have my um native
kidneys will will that help my native
kidneys
oh they didn't take them out no that'll
help yeah now
oh yeah they just no they didn't take
them out
okay but they still have all their
attachments of blood vessels and
arteries and and veins and everything
they have to otherwise they'd be dead
yeah okay good so yeah that'll be very
interesting
to when they do your blood test and
everything and say uh uh
uh so call us every two weeks let us
know and then anytime you go to the
doctor
let us know you can weigh yourself you
can do your own blood pressure
you know you can take your own blood
sugar and all that kind of stuff
you know you know the strips cost about
50 each and you don't need a
prescription to get them
but my blood sugar is good okay
but you know get get some of the test
strips for your urine pee on them like
once a week and make sure
sugar coming through okay okay okay
leslie good to talk to you brother and
give us a call every couple of weeks and
anytime you go to the doctor and
your testimony is going to help a lot of
people so we appreciate you
i sure will thank you so much
god bless you yes sir thank you thank
you and god bless you as well
i appreciate that thank you all right
thank you leslie
now dr wallach april is 44 years old
she's 140 pounds
she's been trying to get pregnant she um
has had three failed in intra um
in vitro fertilization following
their instructions to the tea and she's
wanting to know
why these are failing okay how old is
she
she's 44. okay and she wants to know
what your recommendations are
okay well i can tell you rebecca i've
gotten more women pregnant than any
other man in history
so i've heard
uh okay now um i'm assuming she's still
cycling so we have to know she's still
cycling okay
yes all right now there's several
problems here number one she needs to
get rid of all the bad stuff no fried
foods no processed meats no oils no
glutens no wheat broth iron oats because
she needs to be able to absorb nutrition
for all the equipment inside of her to
work right
because they need the nutrition to work
then she cannot be on statin drugs to
lower cholesterol
i want her to take three eggs twice a
day
three eggs twice a day with soft yolks
soft boils soft poached soft
scrambled and butter hard-boiled eggs
won't count
again no wheat brother oats she needs to
live like an asian living rice and sweet
potatoes and all that kind of stuff
and i'd have her go with a heavy hammer
but she only weighs 140 pounds she's
right on that cusp
um and but since she wants to get
pregnant have her take two healthy brain
and heart packs per month
a full dose of everything twice a day
two healthy brain and hard packs per
month to full dose filling twice a day
i also want her to take the msm one
bottle a month of that so you can take
three twice a day the msm
i want her to take the zera femme
zera femme take three of those um
twice a day that's two bottles a month
for the xerafim it'll help her
make estrogen and progesterone but she
needs to get the eggs because they're 95
by weight cholesterol she cannot be on a
cholesterol-free diet she cannot be
taking any statin drugs
okay gotta get off all the gluten so she
can absorb all the nutrition
and then let's see here
i also want her to take three of the
ocean's gold twice a day and three of
the fucoid z
twice a day and then you know call us
every month and let us know how she's
doing um
and it might take her say two months or
three months to get everything working
here and going
so um she can you know she can practice
and do all the sex she wants between now
and then
and then one day and she can you know
she doesn't need to go to the doctor
she can get test strips from the
pharmacy with no prescription you know
a pregnancy test and pee on it and see
if she's pregnant so she can do all that
herself
and then call us when she's pregnant
because she will get pregnant
i'll put her i'll put her in my plus
column
there you go all right april um so again
everybody
if you want to you know re-listen to
what dr
wallach has said for any specific
condition whether it's yours or
somebody else's that's similar to
somebody you know please go to ask doc
live
to watch the recordings of our
past presentations and
you can pause write it down play
all that is dr wallach has this down pat
he is so sharp i love it next dr wallach
we have mary with her hand up
mary go ahead you are on live with dr
wallach
thank you mary and i have to say
i love you dr wallace oh i'm a lucky man
um yes i have a lady who
weighs 180 pounds
she's five three and a half
she's 35 years old she just
finished uh with the wuhan
flu and she is not gluten free
she is being tested
for pcos
pcos
gosh i have fun polycystic ovary
syndrome
yes okay thank you
okay so she's having pain with her
cycles or
irregular cycles or something going on
right yes
okay anything else any habit pressure
diabetes
arthritis
not diagnosed okay i don't i don't know
about this
does she okay does she complain about
skin problems or bowel problems
no okay all right so she needs to get
rid of all the bad foods at five foot
three i'd like to see her weigh
1 15 120 kind of thing
she weighs 180 so she's maybe 50 60
pounds overweight
so i want her to get on at least one
maybe two
of our keto caramel meals okay um
and she they can't be both at the same
time
you know either the shake or the bar and
then one meal a day and it can be
i'd have her take a meal that's like um
three four five hundred calories you can
eat rice and sweet potatoes you gotta
get rid of all the wheat brother ryan
oates right
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils of any kind no wheat bread around
oats of any kind
there are no such things as gluten-free
oats um no sugar
and then again i'd have her take it at
180 pounds i'd start her out
with um two healthy brained heart packs
per month to full dose everything twice
a day
i'd never take a one bottle of msm so
you can take three of those twice a day
support and promote maintenance repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between the vertebrae bone
makes bone itself
and i also want her to take
uh the woman's fx okay
the woman's fx take three of those twice
a day i want her to take the zera femme
zera femme now she can take three of
those twice a day there's two bottles a
month
okay that's going to deal with her
ovarian cycle problem
okay and she needs those three eggs
twice a day with a soft yolk so she can
make
estrogen and progesterone and then call
us every couple of weeks and let us know
what's going on
okay i think she has had
some bouts with depression
so some of the things that you mentioned
would take care of that yeah no she if
she wants to throw something else in
there and cost isn't an issue she can
throw our de-stress capsules in there
take three of those twice a day two
dollars a month
that can help you know with the brain
function everything but those eggs are
going to do it staying away from all the
bad stuff including sugar
i will do it and and the gluten okay
thank you god bless you dear
all right thank you mary now dr wellick
ralph is riding in he moved from
colorado to arizona
and the last nine months he has had
excessive slim
in his throat every morning um
he thought it was dirty air so he put
electrostatic filter in his heat pump
he got a humidifier for his bedroom his
doctor says it's a desert thing
um and there's nothing that they can do
to help
so anything else any high blood pressure
diabetes arthritis skin problems bowel
problems
he says he has no other conditions okay
and he's how old we know he did not say
how old unfortunately
okay well he's people he's 5 10
he's 5 10 and 185 pounds okay
all right so needs to get rid of all the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
meats no oils and glutens a wheat
brother i know some sugar you've
probably never heard that before
and then he needs two healthy brain and
heart patterns per month two healthy
brain and heart pattern about the food
waste everything twice a day
and then i'd have them take the um
uh ocean's gold take three of those
twice they have two bottles a month
the fucoids z three of those twice a day
there's two bottles a month
and then i'd have them take our killer
biotic have them take three of those
twice
a day there's two bottles a month okay
killer biotic and then i wanted him to
be sure to use
our skin sanitizer uh three or four or
five
times a day i want him to use our
colloidal silver in case there's a
low-grade infection in there what i do
with the collateral silver
i put two droppers full of colloidal
silver on the right side of my mouth
twice um okay
a half hour before breakfast half hour
before lunch half hour before dinner and
half hour before bed
okay i'm not going to go to a doctor and
get shots and injections of drugs and
all that kind of stuff
i use our colloidal silver been doing it
for 73 years
okay colloidal silver you can put it on
your shelf 4 000 years from now it'll
still be good never goes out of date
it was the antibiotic forever until
1938 when they came out with penicillin
then doctors said well heck people can
get colloidal silver
at the at the feed store or
from the veterinarian we want to write a
prescription for it so they started
writing prescription for everything for
penicillin
but still the greatest antibiotic of all
of them is
colloidal silver because it kills
everything okay right
i love it i love it so next dr wallach
we have a comment that's here in the
chat with us today
and susan is five foot four
190 pounds 52
years old has plantar fasciitis
he is on no meds she wants to know what
is
recommended to reverse plantar fasciitis
and she is working on her diet
okay very easy okay she's good because
she needs to get rid of all the bad
stuff
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens no wheat broth right on
oats
no sugar and then i wanted to have two
healthy brain and heart patch a month to
full dose everything twice a day
i want her to get two bottles a month of
our msm so you can take three with each
meal
because plantar fasciitis the fascia is
that
flat tendon on the bottom of your foot
goes from your toes to your heel kind of
thing
um that goes along with sciatica low
back stuff
and let's see here she's 52 years old
she's kind of at that age when people
can get those sort of things
um so i wanted her to have two miles a
month of our msm so we can take three
with each meal
i want her to take three of our vitamin
d3 twice a day there's two bowels a
month i want her to take five
of the glucago capsules
uh three times a day it'll be two miles
a month of our glucogel capsule she
could take the liquid if she wants to be
three quarts of the liquid a month
ounce three times a day or the capsules
you get to have
capsules five capsules twice a day and
the liquid at lunch you know however she
wants to do it but three doses a day of
that
and then for i want her to put some cm
cream with trauma oil in it five drops
of trouble and a teaspoon of seam cream
mix it up really good
because it will separate at night the
cream goes down to the bottom water come
to the top got to stir it up every
morning
and put five drops of the trauma oil in
it and put that on her back
as well as on her feet on the tops
between her toes and on the bottom of
her feet
and then of course we also have another
one called
soothe okay and
soothe is our cbd oil from our hemp fx
division
and we just bought a big factory down in
florida
because our uh sales from our hemp fx
products are just skyrocketing
and so we bought a much bigger factory
down in florida and we're just going
crazy with our hemp fx cbd oils
no thc in it so it's legal in all states
and so you can add the trauma oil to our
cbd oil also
and it's one of those things it's called
soothe
for the topical it comes in a tube it's
for topical discomfort relief
and i i use the soothe if i you know i'm
out working in the yard and i get sort
of like oh man you know
i kind of overdid it here so i'll put
some sooth on my
low back morning no problem i i do that
probably two three times a year
uh because of i do heavy work i'm 82
years old
most people think i'm in my 50s um
because of my energy and i don't have
any wrinkles and things like that
and so um this this hemp fx
um sue that just works great for topical
pain relief
all right fantastic now dr wallach the
next
question that we have and i know i've
had several people with all the stress
that's going on
with different situations around the
world
it's just a general question wanting to
know what would be a protocol for
stomach ulcers
okay well stomach ulcers can be caused
by a bacteria growing in your stomach
it can be caused by a problem called
gastroparesis which is a squeezing of
the 10th cranial nerve by osteoporosis
of the skull
okay it could be caused by gluten
okay um and so what people want to do
is take our colloidal silver because it
kills the bug that causes gastric ulcers
right take a dose
a dropper full two on each side half
hour before breakfast half hour before
lunch half hour before dinner half hour
before bed it'll kill that bug
then they need to take one healthy brain
and heart pack for 100 pounds of body
weight
they need to take msm three of those
twice a day per hundred pounds of body
weight
and then absolutely no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens and
we probably rain oats i'd also have them
take
the ultimate enzymes they could take two
or three of those say five to ten
minutes for each meal
with a couple ounces of water i also
want them to take to taste
our pink himalayan salt we have two
types i take the pink himalayan salt for
breakfast on my rice and sweet potatoes
and my softballed eggs and then i have
our
pink himalayan um salt
with the black pepper ground up in it
for dinner time with my
rice and sweet potatoes and beef and
so forth so i have our pink himalayan
salt twice a day just plain in the
morning
and with black pepper at night and that
will help your stomach make stomach
acid well i don't want something oh yes
you do because stomach acid
helps your stomach stay sterile you do
not want the bugs
growing in there that are going to
create gastric ulcers you don't want
bugs in there fermenting
food and having bloating and belching
and burping and pain
and that's you you have an alkaline
stomach when you have all that so
you want to take your colloidal silver
kill the bugs have our himalayan salt
your chief cells you actually have
specific cells in the walls of your
stomach called chief cells
that take salt and make stomach acid
with it why did god put t
cells in your stomach if he didn't want
you to have acid in your stomach
you break down proteins into amino acid
using
stomach acid okay and so
yeah and you absorb iron and b12 and
other nutrients specifically
when you have stomach acid so you need
to have the pink himalayan salt for
breakfast and dinner
i take the plain pink himalayan salt for
breakfast and the pink himalayan salt
with a ground of black pepper in it at
dinner time
i'm 82 years old and i can kick butt
yes you can yes you can i've seen you
walking around at convention
and people are having a hard time
keeping up with you
so the next question dr wallach is
daniel says hey doc i'm a male six
foot three 285 pounds
22 years old i'm trying to lose weight
and currently not supplementing what
advice would you have for someone
straight out of college
okay become a younger associate no
matter what else you do
part-time become a young giving
associate i will give you free
anybody who signs up and when you renew
every year every year
i will give you and when you sign up i
will give you 500
free worth of business support material
okay every time you sign up when you
first sign up originally and every year
when you renew
i will give you 500 bucks free worth of
business support material okay
then at 285 pounds
optimally he will need three healthy
brain and heart patch per month one per
100 pounds of body weight a full dose of
breakfast lunch and dinner if
finances are an issue don't go any lower
than two okay
you won't get any results he needs
optimally three one full dose three
times a day
at the least amount of full dose twice a
day then he also needs
the um msm i want him to get two bottles
of msm so we can take three with each
meal
help rebuild cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disc between the
vertebrae bone break your bone itself
and then i want him to have our collagen
he needs 15 collagen capsules a day five
with each meal that's two bottles a
month at the capsules of our
glucogen and then i want him to use our
rebound for energy our rebound
for energy it comes in 12 ounce cans and
30 sticks
in a box however he wants to take it i
take two of those 12 ounce cans a day i
only weigh 142.
and then lastly i want him to have at
least one meal a day
better yet two meals a day for a while
or keto caramel meals
okay and he'll he'll lose a half a pound
of two pounds a day
and so within two months he could get
down to
uh 220 pounds where he needs to be at
six foot three
okay and so let's hear from him every
two weeks let's hear from daniel every
two weeks
because i want to have him tell his
story
and um he'll be a great testimony but he
he's gonna have such a great testimony
he really really really needs to sign up
become a younger associate
and he'll get wholesale prices if he
gets on auto ship i will pay the
shipping
i'll do that for everybody you get on
auto ship i pay the shipping
and if you run this out of your house
you can get
thousands of dollars worth of tax breaks
every month you heard me every month you
get thousands of dollars worth of tax
breaks if you get if you run this
longevity business out of your house
you don't need employees okay you don't
need employees you don't need a store
and you get thousands of dollars worth
of tax breaks i mean you got to be a
flipping communist idiot
not to have a youngevity business all
right well
as a young jeopardy distributor and
i love the fact that i am ceo
of my own franchise with youngevity
i am my best employee and how much
weight did you lose
i want daniel to hear this how much
weight did you lose on the program i
have lost 95 pounds on the program
i imagine you're a lot cuter than him
but he'll still lose 95 pounds
you know dr wells the best thing about
it is i'll lose
and it stays off before i start losing
more it's not
yo-yo i'm not losing it gaining it
losing it gaining it i'm
it's not the same 95 pounds that i've
lost three or four times
it's 95 pounds straight thank you for
that that's a beautiful testimony
and um your story helped so many people
rebecca i just really
love you and appreciate you you are an
angel of god
we're just so happy to be working with
you well thank you so much dr wallach
it is my privilege to be able to share
with you
with so many i love it i love it
um okay we are coming to the top of the
hour but i have
a couple um well i've got a testimony
here
that was shared in the chat so
dr wallach we thank you for your
wonderful work and rock solid truth
uh people need to look at the cdc stats
rice and sweet potatoes make a big
difference you've helped my wife our dog
and myself great work and god we trust
john b so thank you so much
john for sharing that waste up the sale
hoist up the sales john b
yeah that's right and then we have dan
so dan says he met you 21 years ago in
eugene oregon
he at the time he had bone on bone in
his right knee
from being torn up in the military and
they had removed the cartilage
so he also couldn't throw a football
skip rock whatever
20 years ago you put him on the pig pack
which is what i started on that's what
we started with yep
yep and he's now 69 years old
five foot seven 180 pounds
he doesn't limp um the arthritis that
he had is now gone he's throwing
footballs skipping rocks
and he can do it all now so he's very
appreciative of you
and it laughed you beautiful thank you
so much for his testimony yeah
yeah you give the body the raw
ingredients and it's amazing what the
body itself can do
and stay away from gluten so you can
absorb them that's right
you want to make sure that you absorb it
so
again we are at the top of the hour we
had a couple more hands up i apologize
for that but
dr wallach has a super busy schedule we
want to respect that as well
so thank you everybody for joining us
with the ask
doc live program we love you dr
wallach and we we love and appreciate
all of you who jumped on with us and all
that are watching the replay
thank you rebecca lieutenant colonel
wallick over and out
over and out sir thank you everybody
again visit fastdoclive.com have a great
one